مشاهدينا سابدا من الخبر العاجل الذي ورد
قبل قليل عن اصطدام سياره بمقر مدخل رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني في العاصمه البريطانيه
لندن هذه الصور الاوليه التي وصلتنا قبل
قليل حيث طوقت الشرطه المكان وتم اعتقال
المشتبه به والذي قام بعمليه الاصطدام
طبعا ليس هناك اي تفاصيل حول هذا الحادث
حتى الساعه عن خلفيات هذه العمليه ان ما
كانت يعني
هناك يعني اي خلفيات ارهابيه او اذا ما
كانت حادثه ذات الدوافع اخرى طبعا بانتظار
مزيد من التفاصيل الرسميه حول هذه العمليه
سنبقى ننقل هذه الصوره من هناك اذا قبل
قليل اعتقلت الشرطه البريطانيه شخص قام
بالاصطدام بسيارته ببوابه مقر رئيس
الوزراء في لندن اذا هذه
الحادثه حصلت قبل قليل وما زالت الشرطه
تطوق المكان وتم اعتقال المشتبه به ليس
معلوم حتى الساعه ان كان هناك يعني اي
دوافع شخصيه ارهابيه ام اذا هناك عاده
يكون البعض لديه مشاكل نفسيه بهكذا حالات
ان كان اطلاق نار او غيره بانتظار طبعا
التفاصيل وبانتصار سينضم الينا بعد قليل
الزميل مصطفى زارو
لنقل الصوره من هناك ولعطائنا مزيد من
التفاصيل حول هذه العمليه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات